>>> WELCOME TO CORNWALL,
EVERYONE.
THE DUCHESS OF CAMBRIDGE, KATE
MIDDLETON MEETING WITH THE FIRST
LADY.
THE QUEEN WILL ALSO BE IN
CORNWALL TO MEET THE SUMMIT
LEADERS IN THE COMING HOURS.
SHE HAS ALREADY MET 12 U.S.
PRESIDENTS.
THAT'S MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
THEM.
MAX FOSTER JOINS ME NOW.
WE ARE LOOKING AT LIVE PICTURES
OF JILL BIDEN MEETING WITH THE
DUCHESS OF CAMBRIDGE AND I
IMAGINE SHE FELT RIGHT AT HOME
WHEN SHE MET CHILDREN A FEW
MOMENTS AGO.
>> THIS IS A ROUNDTABLE OF
EXPERTS ABOUT CHILDREN AND THEIR
WELL-BEING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE DUCHESS
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY FOCUSED
ON, THE WELL-BEING OF YOUNG
CHILDREN AND OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT JILL BIDEN CARES ABOUT AS
WELL.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF A MEDLEY OF
ENGAGEMENTS.
YOU HAVE KATE AND YOU ALSO HAVE
CHARLES AND CAMILLA AND THE
QUEEN IS COMING AS FAR AND SHE
NORMALLY DOESN'T TRAVEL THIS
FAR.
THIS SHOWS HOW THESE PROJECTS
PARTICULARLY CLOSE TO THE HEARTS
OF THE ROYALS WANT TO PROMOTE AS
WELL.
AFTER I AM SURE WE WILL SEE HER
AT THE CENTER OF THE FAMILY
PHOTO AS WELL.
IT'S QUITE POIGNANT TO SEE THE
QUEEN IN THE CENTER OF ALL THAT
POWER.
SHE IS THE LONGEST SERVING HEAD
OF STATE AND SEEMS TO BE THE ONE
PERSON ON THE PLANET THAT OTHERS
DEFER TO.
ALSO SHE'S LESS DIVISIVE.
>> WE HEARD THE FIRST LADY SAY
SHE WAS INL CREDIBLY EXCITED TO
MEET THE QUEEN, ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF BEING HERE IN THE
UK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE MEETING
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL HAVE WITH
THE QUEEN, MAX?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HASN'T MET
THE QUEEN BUT HE IS AN EXPERT ON
THE INTERNATIONAL STAGE AND TELL
UNDERSTAND THE PROTOCOLS.
THE OBAMAS AND TRUMPS HAVE
BROKEN SOME OF THE PROTOCOLS, I
DON'T THINK INTENTIONALLY, BUT
THE BIDENS WILL BE MORE INFIELD
ON THAT.
SUNDAY SHE HOSTS THE BIDENS AT
WINDSOR CASTLE.
BUT TODAY IT IS ABOUT THE QUEEN
REPRESENTING THE UK.
IT IS CHARM OFFENSIVE.
AND CHARLES AND CAMILLA WILL BE
DOWN HERE.
EVENTUALLY THEY WILL BE REAPING
AS HEAD OF STATE AS WELL.
>> YOU SAID IT'S KEY TOPICS, KEY
ISSUES CLOSE TO THEIR HEARTS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT LIVE PICTURES
WITH THE DUCHESS OF CAMBRIDGE.
LATER ON, MAX WE ARE SEEING
PRINCE CHARLES LEADING ON
SUSTAINABILITY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE.
PRINCE CHARLES IS ALSO GETTING
THAT MESSAGE TO WORLD LEADERS AT
THE G7 WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> WE WILL HAVE HIS OWN
ROUNDTABLE.
THESE THINGS ARE OFTEN
NEGOTIATIONS.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL GET TOGETHER
AND THEY WILL DECIDE WE WANT THE
ROYALS DOING THIS PART OF IT.
BUT THE PALACE ALSO WANTS TO
PROMOTE THE ROYALS IN THEIR OWN
INTEREST.
IT'S INTERESTING SEEING HOW SHE
DEVELOPED HER THINKING.
SHE WAS NERVOUS IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS FOR SO LONG.
I THINK DURING LOCKDOWN FOR THE
DUCHESS, SHE HAS DONE MORE VIDEO
CALLS WITHOUT THE FUSS AROUND
HER AND IS MORE COMFORTABLE IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERAS.
SO IF YOU GET HER IN FRONT OF
CAMERAS ON A TOPIC THAT IS DEAR
TO HERE, SHE IS REALLY COMING
OUT.
ANOTHER THING PEOPLE HAVE
POINTED OUT TO ME IS THAT JILL
BIDEN HAS A CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH HARRY.
THIS GOES BACK TO YEARS.
HE WENT WITH MICHELLE OB